[Music]
hey everyone
my name is arjun and today i'm going to
be showing you guys 12
end games that every player should know
so let's get right into it
[Music]
the first end game i'm going to be
showing is one of the most important
rook endings for a chess player to know
and it's called the lucena position so
the way you can recognize the lucena
position
is one side in this case white has a
pass pawn on the seventh rank
i should add white is going upwards
black is going downwards
so anyway one side has a pawn on the
seventh rank
and their king is directly in front of
it so in other words their king is
actually stopping the pawn's progress
meanwhile the other side has their rook
directly behind the pawn
in this case black's king is not
actually threatening to take the pawn
so black white's pawn is not going to
hang anytime soon
and this position is actually going to
be a win but you have to know the proper
the proper sequence to achieve the win
so there are a lot of ways that white
can try to win this and i'll look at a
few of them right now
so of course white is not going to win
unless he can promote his pawn
and win the brook in the process thereby
achieving an easy king and rook
checkmate
so what if white just tries to promote
the pawn immediately by moving the king
out with let's say king to c7
well this may seem like a good idea but
the problem is black can just continue
to check white so black checks if white
ever wanders away too far from the pawn
black will just come back
forcing the white king to return
and if white tries to stay with the pawn
black is just going to keep tracking
forever and white's king is not going to
move anywhere
so it's clear that moving the king out
immediately doesn't work
and because of this annoying king on the
other side it controls these two squares
meaning the king can't move there either
so if we take a closer look at the
position we'll note that black's king is
only cut off by one file
the e file so we need to make that two
files
first we have to cut off the king by
another file by pushing the king to the
side of the board
here black can either move his king to
the g file to one of these squares or he
can move it to e6
if black goes to e6 then probably the
easiest way of winning is just to go
king to e8
and of course black has to take the pawn
now
otherwise white promotes but now i can
check
forcing the king to go here continuing
to protect the rook
check the king has to move and the rook
falls
so if we go back to this position it's
clear that black will have to go
somewhere on the g
file and let's say he goes to g7
now once again we can consider trying to
move the king out to one of these
squares
but once again it's not going to work as
if you come out
black will check and now white can
actually even get as far as the fifth
rank
without hanging the pawn but in this
position
white has to move back and he has not
accomplished anything
so we could try to imagine if only white
had a piece he could put on d4 now
then the rook would simply not be able
to come around and protect the d8 square
so how do we get a piece to d4 well if
only our rook could somehow get there
and that is actually the purpose of
white's second move if we go back a bit
so if we go back here white actually
plays the
somewhat unintuitive rook to f4 and the
idea is he's going to try this exact
same sequence i discussed earlier
where the king comes out and then the
rook will block a check
so let's see that plan in action
so of course black cannot really move
the rook away
because then white can simply bring the
king out anyway
and now if black moves the king he gets
nothing done
and basically it won't really matter
what black does
so let's just say he moves the rook on
the file it doesn't really matter where
now i can bring the king out to e7 or to
c7
black will obviously have to check the
king
like this now
white should bring the king here and
black is obviously forced to check again
now white keeps maneuvering until he can
get the king to d5
like this and now rook to d1 is forced
and we see the the plan we've been
discussing this whole time
or the rook moves to d4 now
black black is forced to take and the
pawn will promote next move
therefore securing an easy win
so the main takeaways from the lucena
position
are first the black king should be cut
off by two or more files which is why we
played the move rook f1
and second after this black white should
move the rook to the fourth rank
so that he can therefore do what's
called building a bridge whereas he
brings the king out
the rook is there to shield a check
the second position is considered also
one of the most important rook endings
to know
and this one is actually called the
philidor position
so to recognize the philidor position
one side in this case we have it black
and black has the black has an extra
pawn
usually it's pretty far advanced in this
case on the fourth rank
and this time instead of black's king
being in front of the pawn
it's white's king so in other words
white's king is in the way of the pawn
so
white's king is going to have to move
out of the way for the pawn to promote
so this position is actually a draw and
that's only for the only reason
that white's king is the one that is
blocking the pawn
so if it was black's turn black could
try and bring the king in
trying to create some annoying mate
threats and if white were to just do
nothing
black and blade move like this and here
it's still a draw actually
but it's definitely going to be a lot
more difficult now
so what white needs to do in order to
draw this position
is he has to take control of the third
rank so note that black's king has no
way of entering the position
of course most of the time if black
chooses to trade the rooks let's say by
doing a maneuver like this
it's just going to be a draw after the
trade so that doesn't do anything
if black simply tries to check white
well white can just
move back and forth and no progress is
made from black
so now sooner or later black is going to
have to play the move d3
and this may look like a pretty menacing
move but it actually isn't going to do
that much
the key strategy here now is to play the
move rookie chain
and the idea is white is now going to
check the king from behind
and black is actually not going to be
able to do too much about it
if we go back to the original position
here
if i tried to do this checking from
behind method here
well if black simply took some space and
white tried checking here
it would still be it would still be in
win actually now for black sorry not a
draw
and once black brings the king in here
now we can see some annoying mate
threats
however the difference between these
positions is
if we look at the position we were
discussing earlier
here once white moves up if black tries
to invade with the king
note that the d3 square is no longer
available for the king
so once white checks of course if the
king strays far away
black white can just continue checking
and now eventually black will is going
to have to agree to a draw
because black can make no progress that
is how you can draw the philidor
position
the third the third position i'm going
to show you is actually pretty much the
same as the second one
and this is actually the exact same this
position has the exact same
characteristics
as the philidor except we'll notice that
this time the pawn is a knight pawn
that is a b-pawn or a g-pawn
here we can use the same drawing
mechanism i discussed earlier
however there's actually an easier way
to draw this time
if we go back to the original position
the previous velador position that is
if we scroll back to the very beginning
from here
i i mentioned the move rook h3 but what
if white tries to play passively
and plays a move like this allowing
something like this to happen
where white just lets black invade
so if we get to some sort of position
like this of course neither side is
playing very good moves here
well if black if white tries to just
defend passively like this let's say
black is going to win eventually and
that is because in this position
black has a nice idea where he can bring
the rook around to the other side
and give checkmate for example if white
continues to do nothing
well in this case black should go king
to e3
and here if white continues to wait
simply move like rook to h2
will just win because now the rook will
get the h
we'll get to h1 and the pawn will have a
clear path to the bottom
so because of this it's clear that
passive defense in this position does
not work
and that's why you have to use the same
method i discussed earlier
where you play rook to h3 stopping the
king from entering
followed by rook hate to check from
behind
however in the position with the knight
pawn black white can throw all that out
of the window
white can just defend passively actually
and he can allow black to get the
optimum positions for all of his pieces
as long as white just keeps the rook on
the first rank
no matter what black does it's actually
still going to be a draw
and we can think of it like this if we
remember the previous position
black would win this by bringing the
rook around
and oh wait there's no file that he can
go that isn't occupied by the king
so black actually is out of files to go
to in this position
there's actually no file to the left of
the a file so black can never actually
checkmate
even if black were to reroute his king
like this the a1 square is never going
to be defended
so it's actually going to still be a
draw and just to illustrate this
if white just keeps maneuvering even if
black tries to move b2 here
threatening to checkmate white can
simply go rook to g3
and take the pawn with a draw so
in this position there's actually
nothing that black can do as i've been
saying
so you can just remember if there's a
knight pawn
in a filidor position that is a b-pawn
or a g-pawn
then white doesn't need to use the same
active defense that i discussed earlier
white can just play the move rook to e1
or rook to the first rank
and simply move the rook back and forth
making sure never to allow checkmates on
the a file
so that's how you can draw a philidor
position when there's a night pawn
the fourth position i'm going to be
showing is one that's not so likely to
appear in an actual game
as usually there are some better
alternatives earlier
but it does a good job of illustrating a
couple of important rook ending
principles
so from here it's black to play in this
position
and black is obviously going to be
trying to draw since white is up a pawn
what black wants to do here is black
just doesn't want to allow the brook to
move out of the way because
of course if the rook ever moves out of
the way the pawn will queen and the game
will be over
so of course black is going to have to
keep his rook on the a file at all times
because if he ever moves away simply
move like let's say rook to c8 is going
to be sufficient
because now regardless of what black
regardless of what black does
let's say black tries to go back white
will queen
and win the rook after takes takes
so from the starting position black is
going to have to keep his rook on the a
file at all times
so black has a couple of ways to try and
draw and let's look at each of them
one way is to just move the king back
and forth
so let's say that white tries to achieve
his goal of course
white needs to get the king somehow over
here
so black just passes back and forth
and it may seem as though white's
position is starting to get a bit scary
after all white's only a few more moves
away from getting to b6
but black actually still has nothing to
worry about
of course the rook will have to move and
now white's king tries to come in
but here we start to come across a kind
of a major problem
once white gets here let's say black can
just start checking white
and white actually has no way of making
it closer to the pawn
without without acknowledging these
checks
so black can just keep on checking if
white comes
pretty far back of course black keeps
the pressure on this pawn
and there's actually no way for white to
make any more progress
so if this type of position comes across
in an actual game
well from you should know that if you
have black in this type of position
the easiest strategy to draw is to just
play king here
and king back and making sure to always
check white if you have your rook
active however what if black makes
oh well can i just bring the king over
and win the pawn
well this may seem like a very good idea
but if what if you try it it actually
illustrates a nice endgame principle
that's very important to know
so black white will have to try the
exact same technique
bringing the king over while by bringing
it up
now let's say black checks it doesn't
really matter white can go here
and now black thinks okay well now i'm
going to get the king over right
actually white is completely winning now
and that's due to a nice tactic
involving a skewer
why can play the move rook to h8
threatening to clean the pond
however of course wouldn't black just
take
well now white goes here and he's going
to win the rook next move
like this so the key to avoiding this
tactic if you have black
is you have to make sure if you get a
position like this never let your king
stray further than the f-file
or the third file from the edge of the
board
if black does this he's actually just
going to lose so it's important to keep
the king
in the corner which seems like it may
not be such a good idea
since usually we're told to keep our
king active in end games however this
case is actually a major exception to
that rule
the fifth ending i'm going to be showing
involves a queen
versus a past pawn on the seventh rank
so as you can see white is up a queen
meanwhile black has this past pawn on
the seventh
and at the moment it's actually blocked
by his king
so clearly white is the one playing for
the win because if white can ever stop
this pawn from promoting permanently
then white will just bring the king in
win the pawn
and then checkmate so it's up to white
to find a way
of doing so so of course white is never
going to win this game without his king
so what white needs to do is white needs
to try and bring the king one step
closer
every chance he gets at the moment since
black's king is blocking its pawn
black can't push pawn and which of
course would always be a draw
so in this position white can bring the
king one step closer with king to b7
now of course black will have to move
the king out of the way since it's the
only legal move
and let's say he moves to f2
now what white has to do is white has to
somehow force the king to go back in
front of its pawn
because of course if the pawn can
promote then the king is never going to
be able to get closer
so what white needs to do is white needs
to start bringing the queen gradually
closer and closer to the black king
he can only do this by giving lots of
checks so i would recommend starting
with the
queen to f5 so after queen f5
black has a few squares to go to note
that if the king ever moves to e1
white can simply bring the king further
since of course there's no threat to
queen
so from here black should probably go to
one of these few squares
let's say he goes here now like i said
earlier white wants to keep bringing the
queen gradually closer and closer
white can play this track forcing the
king to move to the side
and now i can check again forcing the
king to go back
but now how does white win how can white
get the queen any closer without
allowing the pawn to promote
of course if white goes back and forth
he makes no progress
so white has to use a nice endgame idea
white has to play the move queen to e3
even though this isn't check clearly
queening would hang the pawn
so now black is forced to move the king
to the first rank
now white has one nice weight of winning
and that has to play queen f3
forcing the king to go in front of the
pond
note that in this position the king as
well as the pond are both being
simultaneously attacked
once the king goes in front white can
simply bring the king one step closer
and now we repeat the exact same process
black brings the king out threatening to
queen
white begins checking gradually edging
closer and closer
and now we have the key the way of
remembering this
is if the king is ever one file apart
that is there's one file in between the
king and its pawn
white should always try and move the
queen to one square behind the pawn
so in this case e3 if white can do this
that'll therefore force the king to go
back and if the king is ever on the
first rank
most of the time it's pretty easy to win
just by giving enough checks
until the king is forced to move in
front of its pawn
and now the king will edge closer and
closer
so if we continue with the same path as
usual by gradually checking the king
if the king goes here we have the exact
same idea remember
the king is still one file apart from
its pawn and therefore we can move the
queen
one square behind the pawn this time
it's check
and from here we check again and from
here it's not too difficult to win
anymore
the king moves out of the way and now
white can actually just play queen to d3
because the king of course protects the
queen now once again
the king has to go in front of the pawn
and now simply king to e3
should win after king to f1 only legal
move
the pawn falls and soon mate will be
delivered
this this strategy will work for any
pawn when you have a queen versus pawn
position
unless it's a rook pawn that is an a or
h pawn or a bishop pawn
a c or f pawn and i'll be discussing
both of those cases later
to win this type of position there are
three things you need to remember
the first thing is whenever the king is
in front of its pawn
you can bring the king closer the second
thing is
whenever the king is two files away from
the pawn that is there's a file
separating them
you should try and bring the queen one
square in front of the pawn
and third whenever the king is one
square diagonally from the pawn
you have to find a check that forces the
king in front that is for example if we
go through the line i discussed earlier
let's say we have a position like this
these are all moves i've discussed
previously you have to find
one move that forces the king in front
of the pawn and in this case that would
just be queen to f3
pushing the king in front and from here
you can just repeat the process
bring the king closer force the king two
files away
and then so on and so forth
the sixth end game i'm going to show is
similar to the last one
that is there's a pawn on the seventh
once again the opposing side has a queen
and the pawn is one square away from
promotion
however the previous position i showed
had a central pawn a king or a queen
pond
however this position involves a bishop
pond which in this case is the f pond
i should add white is still moving
upwards black is still moving downwards
so in this position it's black to move
of course if what if it was white to
move white would just queen
so black can use the same method i
taught last time
by playing this move and forcing this
and from here black may feel pretty
confident it looks like black is just
going to bring the king in
right well that's true but that's only
for now
once white brings the king out of the
way now black can give some checks
forcing the king over and remember in
this position
there's one file separating the king and
the king in the pawn
now black can use the technique i
described earlier putting the queen one
square behind the pawn
now this is forced of course
sorry and now it may look as though
white has to move in front of the pawn
right well actually no i'll give you a
few seconds to try and find the drawing
idea
that's right the king actually doesn't
need to go in front of its pawn
here white can move the king to the
corner because if takes
well we have stalemate and
actually this motif will work no matter
whether it's an f pawn or a c pawn
whenever the queen tries to check the
king can simply move to the corner
so from here after king to the corner
if black just keeps checking well no
progress is made
so from here the main takeaways from
this
from this type of position are first
you have to remember the stalemating
trick
and second the key is to actually keep
the king
towards the corner that is if the king
keeps wandering away on this side
well it's not going to be a draw because
there is no stalemating technique on
this side
if black if white just goes back to the
other side
well there's suddenly not going to be a
stalemating trick because in a position
like this
of course this is just going to
immediately lose
so we have to remember keep the king
towards the corner
when you're trying to draw this position
and of course whenever the queen tries
to get too close
make sure that you have the stalemate
trick ready
the next position i'm going to be
showing is where there's a king and
queen
except this time the past pawn that's on
the seventh rank happens to be a rook
pond
so from here we can see that once again
of course white is going upwards black
is coming downwards
and you may know that rook pawns often
tend to be exceptions in a lot of end
games like for example in rook endings
are one and the same holds true when you
have a queen versus a pawn ending
so in this position white black can do a
lot of things
but to follow with the principles he
might want to play king to b2 simply
bringing the king closer
as the king is in the corner black white
can simply bring the king out
and now white black will try the exact
same drawing technique
forcing the king back into the corner
by using the same techniques
so he follows all the techniques until
here
but now normally white would be forced
to move into the corner
and he still is but now you notice if
black brings the king further we reach a
stalemate
that's because there is no file to the
right of the h file that the black that
the white king can go to
because of that this position is
actually a dead draw
there are no other ways for white for
black to check for black to
force white into the corner without
using the g file
note that whenever the queen steps onto
the g file regardless of whether king h8
is forced
white can actually just go there anyway
because well black's queen will have to
move again
and we reach the same draw
there's no way for black to force the
king into the corner without using this
technique
in this exact case of course white can
never wander too far away
because black's queen will get in front
of the pond
and therefore if black if white just
sticks to the plan
by playing like this there's never going
to be any progress made and the game
will end in a draw
the eighth end game i'm going to be
showing is very similar to the last one
that i showed
in that there's a queen for one side and
a rook pawn for the other
however this time the rook pawn is not
yet on the seventh rank
and we already discussed if the pawn is
on the seventh it's an easy draw
however if the pawn is on the sixth
there is actually a win for white
so there are a few ways of achieving
this win
but the easiest way is to follow kind of
the same principles i discussed earlier
where you gradually try and bring the
queen closer with checks
and eventually there's a special motif
i'm going to be showing
so the easiest way to to win is of
course to bring the queen
to gradually bring the queen closer like
this for example
and we bring the queen pretty close to
the king and
now the strategy is we want to check on
the g file
so the file next to the pawn so we can
play it move queen to g5 check
now there are a few options for black if
the king ever moves in front of the pawn
there are several ways of winning but
you can just play king to b7 and you'll
eventually win
so probably the king should go here
now we can use the same techniques i
discussed in all of the previous end
games involving queens
where note that the king is two files
away from its pawn
so white can check right behind the pawn
forcing the king over and here
and now of course the king has to go in
front but
now we notice well the king can just
come in
but actually it's even easier than this
after king h1 the h pawn is hanging and
since kh1 is the only legal move
takes is just immediately going to win
the game
so that is one of the techniques that
you can use to win and another technique
involves a nice technique a nice trap
that you can set
so if we go back to the beginning of
course we know that if the h pawn ever
pushes it's a draw
but there's one thing that is that is
different about this position
if white plays a move like queen to f4
let's say the h pawn can't push
and that's because we have queen f1
checkmate
so based on that we can conclude if the
if the king is in the corner and the h
pawn is on h2
if the queen can check on f1 it'll
actually going to be made
so we can just keep threatening the f1
square
once the king moves out of the way of
course here queen to g3 is going to win
the pawn
so king to g2 now we can just use the
same techniques as before
where we check forcing the king in front
bring the king up
and oops the pawn is hanging so
we just win those are some of the
methods that i would recommend using to
win a position
where we have a queen versus an h pawn
but the h pawn is instead of the seventh
on the sixth rank
the ninth end game i'm discussing today
is a more complicated one
and this one made may deserve more
careful study than some of the others
so we notice that black is up two pawns
and they're both pretty far advanced
so is it time to get scared with white
actually
not at all this is a dead drawn position
but it does require some skill to hold
it
basically what we can start by doing is
imagining what if the bishop
and both of these pawns were taken off
the board
well we noticed that black will only
have a king and a bishop
meanwhile white will just have a king so
that's obviously a book draw because
there's no way to make progress
so based on that we can reverse engineer
that white would always be happy
to sacrifice his bishop for black's two
pawns
that makes sense right so
basically what white wants to do is if
black ever pushes his bonds
white can simply sacrifice his bishop
for both of them
so because of that we know that if black
is ever able to push one pawn
white has either has to find something
special or be able to sacrifice his
bishop for both of them
so the way i would start by drawing this
is i would play the move bishop to b3
check
and giving a check is usually not a bad
idea unless black has something specific
he can do
so let's say black goes to e5
now surprisingly the only drawing move
is to play bishop c2
the idea is if black ever pushes this
d-pawn
then white can take it so for example if
pushes
takes takes takes is a draw
and and if black just does nothing by
let's say moving the king
well white can simply just wait if black
never pushes his d-pawn
or this e-pawn let's say it's just going
to be a draw because he cannot make any
progress
note that the bishop is actually
especially useful on c2 slash b1
because it also threatens the e4 pawn so
the king can never run away
because you can just take the pawn
so sooner or later if we get to a
position like this
black is going to have to push his e
pawn
and pushing the e pawn is actually a
pretty simple draw now
white can simply just put his king in
front of the pawn
and now whatever black does what can put
the bishop in front of the other pawn
and because of this bishop's inability
to control light squares
this is actually a dead draw whenever
black's king moves
all white has to do is keep control of
the d3 square at all times
so no matter where black positions the
rest of his pieces
it's going to be a draw because the d3
pawn the d4 pawn can never move to d3
so after digesting all of this if we go
back to the original position
you may wonder well let's say after tt5
well we've already discussed stopping
the d3 pawn push
so why can't you play let's say bishop
to c4
doesn't this also stop d3 because of
course takes takes takes is a draw
well yes and no it does stop the move d3
but actually black is winning this time
and the reason is because
the bishop on c2 was especially useful
in a position like this
because not only does it stop the d3
push it also threatens e4
and the point of threatening e4 is of
course black's king can never wander
away
however if we go back to the position
where we put the bishop on c4
the e4 pawn is not even threatened so
though of course it still takes some
care to win as black
black can actually just move the king
wherever he would like
let's say to f4
now if if white tries to keep the bishop
on this diagonal
there are some ways of trying to win
this and they are not the easiest though
but the but black the point is black can
just move the king
and from here since the e4 pawn is of
course not under
attack there's nothing that white can do
to stop black's king from roaming
so that's why the c2 bishop is such an
important square
so from here as i discussed earlier of
course e3 can never be played
but black might try to do something like
this
if he tries checking what if he tries to
bring the king around this way
and the answer is that actually nothing
will really happen
as long as white always keeps the bishop
on this diagonal
threatening e4 and stopping the push to
d3 it's just going to be a draw no
matter what black tries
so the keys to this end game are first
of all
if we go back to the initial position
always make sure that your bishop is on
c2 or whatever square
attacks upon and stops the other pawn
from pushing
this is especially important because the
king cannot be allowed to wander
second of all you need to make sure if
black ever pushes the other pawn
in this case e3 that you can set up
what's called a blockade
and as i described earlier if pushes you
can go here
and always keep the d3 square under
control
you have to make sure that this can
always be set up if one of the pawns is
pushed
the next sunday i'm going to be showing
illustrates an incredibly important
concept
that every player needs to know
this concept is called the concept of
the outside past pawn
so at first glance this might seem like
a pretty scary position for white to
deal with
after all black has an active king an
advanced past pawn
and it doesn't really look like white's
pawns are doing too much anywhere
however this is actually a winning
position for white
the reason lies in what's called an
outside past pawn
so what white needs to do is white wants
to create a past pawn
on this side of the board so if we can
just imagine for a second
let's say that both of the g pawns were
removed from the position
if that position were to happen let's
just say we can play a move like this
and this is basically the exact same as
the g pawns being removed
because we have the two g pawns here and
if we go forward with that sequence
the g pawns have now gone missing
so if we imagine this position it might
seem like black is still doing well
because as you can see his pawn is still
pretty far advanced
his king is still active and white's
king is still not doing much
however this is actually a pretty easy
win for white and that's because
if black tries to push his pawn white
can simply push his
eventually black will be forced to run
after it
now white can take the pawn and if black
takes this pawn
well you'll see white is just too fast
to reach the side of the board
black can try as much as he would like
to come back over
but ultimately white is just going to be
up two pawns for nothing
and this is a pretty easy win
so if we go back to the original
position we can see that if
white is able to create some past pawn
of the h file he can use it to deflect
black's king as a decoy essentially
to win black's pawn and then proceed to
win the queen side
so because of that white should start
with the move h3
as this move will hope to create a past
pawn
so there are some options for black here
of course we already discussed this g
takes h3 position
as weiken simply pushes pawn on the king
side ultimately grab black's pawn
and bring it over
so let's say black doesn't play g takes
h3 and instead
he just waits on the queen side
well here the easiest way to win is just
to take the g4 pawn
after king takes we reach the same
position where white had an outside past
h-pawn
except this time he has a g pawn
now white can come up with his king
hoping to eat this pawn
now if black keeps defending there's a
nice move that white can play it's not
strictly necessary of course
but white can play the move g4
now of course if the king waits white
will push the pawn and
sooner or later black is going to have
to take it allowing recaptures
so from here this is basically the same
position we would have reached by any
other sequence
black will try in vain to reach the
queen side
but white is simply too fast and
eventually the queenside pawns will just
be lost
so what are some of the key takeaways
from this end game
well if we go back to the beginning
first of all an outside pass pawn is a
very valuable asset and an ending
an outside pass pawn can be defined by a
pawn
that is far away from the remaining
pawns so
therefore if we consider that these
pawns on the queen side are the
remaining pawns
we notice if white is able to create a
past h pawn it'll be further away from
the remaining pawns than black's past e
pawn
so eventually black can use the pawn as
a decoy
to lure black's king away and eventually
white is going to come over and take all
of black's pawns
that is how you can win an end game like
this
the 11th ending i'm going to be showing
illustrates a relatively simple but
often hard to understand concept
and this concept is known as
triangulation
though it sounds like a complicated word
triangulation simply means
wasting a move to get to turn a position
into a better position
so there are already a lot of things to
be considered in the original position
of course white wants to promote his
past pawn while black wants to stop him
so what are white's options and what
does black do about each
let's say that white brings the king up
well
black of course will will will take the
opposition by doing this
and if white ever retreats black can
just copy
so if white pushes we actually just
reach a draw because
this is a well-known drawn position
so if white tries to go king to e6 king
to e8 will simply stop white from making
any further progress in this line
what if white tries to move king to f5
if black does nothing
white can just come in and win blocks h
pawn which should be an easy win
however the problem for white is black
can just play the move king to f7
now white is forced to move back and
black can come back as well
now we've just reached the initial
starting position so it's clear
white hasn't done something right
so white has a few other options white
can either move the king to the side
which would allow a simple move like
king to f7 forcing a repetition
or he can move the king back to a square
like e4 or f4
so let's say white moves to e4
take a second and see what would you
play if you had the black pieces
of course white is still winning this
position but it's interesting to see
what but it's interesting to try and
figure out what the best defense is for
black
so let's take a look at some of the
consequences of this position
if black plays a move king to f7 white
can simply bring the king up
and now if black moves back then white
will come in and win h6
with an easy win
however what if black moves to the side
like this
well if white tries to come back we
reach the starting position once again
and if white plays this move and
in this position if white plays here
black will just come back
now this will reach us back to the
starting position
so it's pretty clear that king e8 is
probably the best way for black to play
but what does white do now well
simply moving the king forward is not
going to do anything
because as we already discussed black
has good responses to each
what white needs to do is he has to wait
another move
white has to play to move king to f4
so you'll notice that of course king to
f7 loses again due to king f5 and the
king infiltrating
so f7 is actually a poison square for
black unless white's king is already on
f5
you also will remember that in the
original position
what white wanted to do was white wanted
to reach this position
except he wanted it to be black's move
so black would have to move back
and white would push with the opposition
so if we go back to the position that
we've been discussing
right here then it's clear of course
king f7 doesn't work
and king f8 is therefore the only option
so from here white can actually play the
move king to
e5 and now the idea is
if black moves to the side like he has
been trying a lot
white can go king e6 and now we actually
reached a position we already discussed
a lot earlier
which specifically would be this one
except in this position it's white to
move meaning black has the opposition
but in the position that we're on right
now after
the following sequence
it's black's move allowing this move
followed by push
here and here soon to be a promotion
so therefore it's pretty clear that
after king to e5 king e8 will lose
because white will get the opposition
and we already know that
the move king to f7 will lose in pretty
much any position
because this is a poison square unless
white's king is on f5
but here since it's black's turn black
can move back
and white will come in and win the pawn
soon to beat the game
however there is one last trick left for
black in this line
so from this position after king to e5
in this line with king's e8
after pushes here here you're
king up well i can play this move and
now
black may hope that white will
immediately play f8 queen
but this is actually just a draw due to
stalemate so white has to be very
careful
the easiest way to win is just to wait
one move with the king
and now once the king moves queening
will be with check
so this is a pretty easily won position
therefore the main takeaways from this
end game are
white needs to wait until he can get a
position where it's
where it's the favorable sides turn to
move that is he has to wait a few moves
and then bring his king back to e5
because now black is forced to make a
move he doesn't want to
that is he's in zugzwang he has to play
king f7 or king e8
and after either of those moves white
has a specific corresponding move that
will win the game
the final end game i'm going to be
showing today shows it shows several
nice principles that i think are very
important to learn
so in this position once again white is
moving upwards black is coming downwards
and we see that actually in this
position it starts off as black to move
so there are a lot of options for what
black can do
black of course wants to win black
white's pawn while white if possible
will take black's pawn
so from here what if black tries to
immediately grab white's pawn with the
move king to d4
if black tries this then white can
actually play the move king f5
and now we are in a place of reciprocal
zugswang as it is sometimes called
whoever side to move actually loses
since it's black's turn black will have
to move away and after
white takes it's an easy win for white
similarly if it were white's turn white
would have to move away and then black
would take
winning the pawn and the game
therefore king to d4 is not an
acceptable move for black to play
the king to d6 is an option for black
which we may discuss later
but let's say black tries king to c4
intending to come around the pawn from
behind
now the idea is let's say white just
plays a move like king to f5
then all of a sudden we reach a position
that we got earlier where this time it's
actually white to move so black will win
the game
therefore white should not play king to
f5
what if white tries king to g5 simply
copying black
well then what if black plays king to d4
well we've fallen into the same trap as
before where this time it's black to
move
and the pawn is lost
however black doesn't need to do this
black can actually play the move king to
d3
of course white has to protect the pawn
otherwise he loses
but we'll find that he will lose anyway
because now once the king moves away
black wins the pawn and with the game
so what has white done wrong it seems
like king to d3 is just an inevitable
consequence
right well not exactly white has one
trial left to him
since we've already discussed these two
moves white will have to bring the king
back
and hope to survive if white just
tries to play this move well black can
simply come and attack the pawn white
will protect it
black will push sorry he will he will
push the king up
and now it seems as though white is just
going to lose right
he'll lose the pawn and with the game
however king e2 is actually a blunder
here
since after this position we reach a
well-known win
because black will have the black will
be able to push his pawn
therefore in this position white
actually has to play the move king f2
and this is actually going to be a draw
because if black takes
white has the opposition and it's well
known that this type of position
is a pretty easy draw for the defender
therefore what can we take away from
this position in the end it was simply a
draw
but there were a lot of interesting
ideas that were presented along the way
remember if the king ever moves to this
square in this case d4
whoever side to move it is in this
position will lose
a common idea in these types of
positions is to try and come around
behind
like this and that was illustrated in
this variation
where black attacks the pawn from behind
forcing the cane to move to the deadly
square
where this will win and at the very end
we found that this that the easiest way
to draw and as a matter of fact the only
way to draw for white
is to simply play passively which is
typically not a good idea in other
endings
but in this exact case it is eventually
white can go back to the textbook draw
of king and pawn versus king where the
defender has the opposition
and we reached a well-known stalemate
type of position
at the very end
so those were all the 12 end games i
showed today
i hope you all enjoyed and learned
something thank you all for watching
and i'll see you all next time
[Music]
you